dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jennifer here I think
we're in a moment of history we're
probably the most important thing we
need to do is to bring the country
together and one of the skills that I
bring to bear new magento yeah sure Bala
Azula sonar Conn Washoe ha
[Music]
this is my reality and is this reality
of my people for decades for centuries
this work is about creating facial
animation from speech in real-time hmm
this means that after recording the
audio footage of us speaking we give it
to a learning algorithm which creates a
high quality animation depicting our
digital characters uttering these words
this learning algorithm is a
convolutional neural network which was
trained on as little as 3 to 5 minutes
of footage per actor and was able to
generalize its knowledge from this
training data to a variety of real-world
expressions and words and if you think
you've seen everything
you should watch until the end of the
video as it gets better than that
because of two reasons reason number one
it not only takes audio input but we can
also specify an emotional state that the
character should express when uttering
these words
you do not understand what it is to
are those your Asian Footwear cowboy
chaps or jolly earthmoving headgear with
tenure Suzy have all the more pleasure
for yachting
are those your Asian Footwear cowboy
chaps or jolly earthmoving headgear with
tenure Suzy have all the more pleasure
are those your Asian Footwear cowboy
chaps or jolly earthmoving headgear
number two and this is the best part we
can also combine this together with
deepmind's wavenet which synthesizes
audio from our text input it basically
synthesizes a believable human voice and
says whatever text we write down and
then that sound clip can be used with
this technique to make a digital
character say what we have written so we
can go from text to speech with wavenet
and put the speech onto a virtual actor
with this work
the avocado is a pear shape
with leathery skin smooth edible flesh
in a large stone the avocado is a
pear-shaped fruit with leathery skin to
smooth edible flesh and a large stone
the avocado is a pear-shaped fruit with
leathery skin smooth edible flesh and a
large stone this way we get a whole
pipeline that works by learning and does
everything for us in the most convenient
way no actors need it for voiceovers no
motion capture for animations this is
truly incredible and if you look at the
left side you can see that in their
video there is some two minute papers
action going on how cool is that make
sure to have a look at the paper to see
the three-way lost function the author's
came up with to make sure that the
results were correctly for longer
animations and of course in research we
have to prove that our results are
better than previous techniques to
accomplish this there are plenty of
comparisons in the supplementary video
but we need more than that since these
results cannot be boiled down to a
mathematical theorem that we need to
prove we have to do it some other way
and the ultimate goal is that a human
being would judge these videos as being
real with a higher chance than one made
with a previous technique this is the
core idea behind the user study carried
out in the paper we bring in a bunch of
people present them with a video of the
old and new technique without knowing
which is which and ask them which one
they feel to be more natural and the
result was not even close the new method
is not only better overall but I haven't
found a single case scenario or language
where it didn't come out ahead and
that's extremely rare in research
typically in a maturing field new
techniques introduce a different kind of
trade-off for instance less execution
time but at the cost of higher memory
consumption is a classical case but here
is just simply better in every regard
excellent
listen up the train yard will houses is
our main objective now let's say you and
your men will do that you have to go in
and out very quick I want you to get all
the ammo and weapons that you can carry
and come back as quickly as you can you
understand if you enjoyed this episode
and would like to help us make better
videos in the future please consider
supporting us on patreon you can pick up
cool perks like watching these episodes
in early access details are available in
the video description beyond telling
these important research stories we are
also using part of these funds to
empower other research projects I just
made a small write-up about this which
is available on our patreon page the
link is in the video description make
sure to have a look thanks for watching
and for your generous support now see
you next time
[Music]